so then the UK is rapidly becoming one
of the worst affected in Europe by
coronavirus there have been more than
500 deaths in 24 hours for the first
time and this spike comes as a 4,000 bed
hospital is due to open in East London
to treat covered 19 patients the
temporary hospital was set up in two
weeks the government is under growing
pressure to increase testing especially
for its National Health Service staff
nearly 30,000 people are infected with
the virus let's go straight away to our
correspondent Rory challenge is live for
us in London he's outside the convention
centre that's being turned into a
hospital right there Rory first of all
the numbers now reach the alarming
proportions in the UK yeah over the last
couple of days there has been a very
steep curve upwards in the daily deaths
also the latest figures from the NHS are
that 563 people died inside Britain's
hospitals and that's important because
there will be a number of people who've
died outside of Britain's hospitals in
care homes or or their own homes etc or
perhaps by 20 percent more those figures
will creep in over the next week or so
but going back to yesterday the figure
was 381 the day before that was 180 you
can see how fast the death toll is
increasing in the UK at the moment and
the the advice or the warnings that the
government is giving out is that we're
nowhere near the the peak of this yet so
we've still got another couple of weeks
if you look at the figures if you look
at the stats that are being published
the UK is plotting pretty much the same
trajectory that Italy was doing about
two weeks ago or so so the UK is
seemingly on course for the same kind of
effect the coronavirus has had on the
country as Italy and that's why this is
needed because this facility here know
if it's 4,000 beds
eventually will be coping with the the
onslaught that kovat 19 is having on the
established
because of the United Kingdom so this
one here in London is the first but
there are going to be others there's one
being constructed in in Manchester
another one in Birmingham and perhaps
more elsewhere in the country too to try
and mitigate the the effects that the
coronavirus is having on a very over
stretched National Health Service right
and as fatalities rise Rory
people will point no doubt at the WHI
advise to test as much as you can when
the UK seems to have been well behind
the curve on that yeah it has been for
some time this is something that the
government is playing catch-up on it's
not just testing it's also the
availability of ventilators and personal
protective gear for health workers on
the frontline all of these things are
very hot issues at the moment but
drilling down into the into the testing
issue yes the the WH Joe is saying test
test test but when you look at the
number of tests actually being conducted
in the UK at the moment maybe eight
thousand a day and compare that to
Germany which is conducting many times
that number of tests so why is the UK
lacking so far behind well the
government says we have not had access
and this is a global problem they say to
the right chemicals for testing we
haven't had access to the right amount
of laboratory capacity and we don't have
the right testing kits that is an
argument that carries some truth
certainly but you've had chemical
companies over the last day or so and
academic institutions saying hold on a
second we've been offering you our help
for some time now and we haven't had
that offer taken up so it does seem like
there is a problem here with the UK
trying to do what it says it's doing and
ramping up testing at the moment the
testing is being done in hospitals and
now in mobile testing centres elsewhere
in the country
predominantly the testing has been done
on on patients but what they're trying
to do is
of the frontline medical staff the
testing that they have long been asking
for all right that's a pitcher in the UK
where there have been more than 500
deaths in 24 hours for the first time
Rory thanks very much indeed
well while the focus is on treating
thousands of sick people millions more
in the United Kingdom are adapting to a
different way of life earlier my
colleagues are hell Raman spoke to a
Chester couple Stephen and Nicola Downey
about how the pandemic is affecting
their family you know just at home we're
currently watching telly hopefully yeah
it's tricky but so obviously you've lost
your job at the moment Nicola obviously
as a school teacher the rules are
different for you because you're a key
worker I'm not at work at the moment on
Friday and we'll be going to another
primary school to help out there and
it's been really tricky planning lessons
three different year groups whilst I'm
Florence who's three and a half at home
I'm trying to keep her entertained
educate as well I'm sure it is difficult
as young parents are you and confident
that you have you might say the
protective equipment you need when
you're going into schools what has been
offered to you it continuously change in
so there's more things in place now so
such as having bags for our clothes and
once we finish work again distancing
ourselves from the children everything's
labeled for individual children who are
in obviously numbers are reduced but
they're still and I when I go in they'll
be 18 children in and six members of
staff so that's still quite no quite a
large gathering of individuals at the
end of the day you both have
professional lives as Steve and
obviously your families in Chester as
well I presume how difficult has it been
keeping in touch with them when you
actually can't see them physically
yes it's tough for me with require
close-knit family so you know we you see
each other daily so it's it's quite so
if I know my mum and dad are not leaving
the house at all and so you know I get
to seen through the window dropping off
shopping and stuff which is nice but
it's just Florence not see her
grandparents and their cousins when
they're we see them at least twice twice
a week three times a week and it's hard
for her to understand why we're not
going to granny's now and that's really
tricky to explain to her